a year ago a pro-trump mob breached the
u.s capitol
you know it's going to stand like 911
does in the memories of people who
witnessed it which is to say it's going
to be one of those things that you never
forget
they broke the glass the attack which
disrupted the count to certify president
joe biden's election is now the subject
of congressional and criminal
investigations
and what happened that day how serious
it was and who's to blame has divided
americans and fractured relationships
between lawmakers
the events of january 6 have created new
divisions in the capital but also a new
intensity of divisions in the capitol
dome
so what's been done since the riot to
prosecute those involved what's still
being investigated and what impact could
january 6 have on the 2022 midterm
elections
we know that the president of the united
states incited this insurrection
this armed rebellion against our common
country in the immediate aftermath of
january 6 the house impeached president
trump for an unprecedented second time
charging him with inciting the riot
the senate later voted to acquit despite
seven republicans voting to convict the
former president it would be the cause
of partisan divisions and democrats were
going to take one position which is that
president trump and those around him
were responsible for historic
responsibility for what happened on
january 6 and republicans would say no
no that's not true nobody in republican
leadership at the white house or in
congress asked people to break into the
capitol and wreak havoc overall more
than 700 people have been arrested in
connection with the attack including
members of far-right groups like the
proud boys and oath keepers though a
vast majority of those charged weren't
affiliated with any such entity
but for some lawmakers mainly democrats
prosecuting the rioters hasn't been
enough in june the house voted largely
along party lines to form a select
committee to investigate january 6th
democrats created this committee said
that there would be an accounting of
what happened on january 6. the
impeachment proceedings were not an
accounting but a trial against an
individual that left vast swathes of
territory uninvestigated
so far the committee has interviewed
more than 300 people and issued more
than 50 subpoenas a lot of those to
former white house officials and
pro-trump organizers
a lot of the findings of the committee
are being closely held the committee is
planning this year to hold public
hearing to lay out from start to finish
what happened
as the committee looks to intensify its
work in the coming year republicans
claims that it's a partisan effort also
grow pelosi has created a sham process
there is already acrimony between the
republicans and the democrats but the
committee's work has intensified the
acrimony in part because the committee
is starting to ask questions of some
members of congress themselves and the
implication is there are probably a lot
more house republicans who the committee
would like to hear from
in in a way the two sides have moved
further into their corners since january
6 republicans
have become
ever more
strident in claiming the election was
stolen from donald trump and democrats
have become ever more strident in saying
basically democracy is at risk because
of what happened
there is no evidence of widespread fraud
and audits of millions of ballots in key
states affirmed the presidential result
[Music]
on january 6 congress did reconvene to
certify the 2020 election results
but when it did 139 house republicans
still voted against certification
now some house democrats are refusing to
work with those lawmakers and verbal
disputes between the parties are
commonplace without the goodwill that
exists to kind of grease the wheels
things that should be happening simply
don't happen and that is a problem for
the country
members of congress increasingly fear
for their safety too more than 9 000
threats were made against lawmakers in
2021 up from about 4 000 in 2017
according to the capitol police the
typical threats are a big problem
i remember the very first week that i
started covering the hill for the wall
street journal was the week that gabby
giffords got shot and
there's a sense that instead of stepping
back from that sort of precipice
the country is only
deepening its entanglement with that
sort of physical violence
congress's divide reflects the country's
split in a november wsj poll 57 of
republicans said the election was stolen
from trump compared to just 3 percent of
democrats
this divide could have implications for
both parties on what will happen in this
year's midterm elections for republicans
there's going to be a first test of who
wins in the republican primaries the
trump true believers or the more
conventional republicans who want to
move on and for democrats
there's the second question of whether
democrats can or will use this debate uh
in the general election try to use it to
their benefit by saying essentially this
is dangerous
you shouldn't be electing people who
question the results of national
elections i think democrats have some
deciding to do here about whether they
want to continue to focus on this
subject or
move on in their own way
some house members aren't even going to
face that choice 25 democrats and 11
republicans have said they will retire
or seek another office
republicans are favored to win the house
and potentially win the senate if the
gop takes control the party will also
gain control of the january 6th
committee it's not just possible that if
republicans win control in 2022 they
will dissolve the committee it's likely
that house republicans will dissolve
that january 6 committee if they win
control of the public for the country
the debate over january 6th and the 2020
results has created an issue that could
have a more lasting impact in the
november wsj poll 64 of republicans and
42 percent of voters overall said they
did not have confidence in the election
system if one of the effects of this
this being the election in january 6th
is that that confidence is permanently
eroded then i think we're headed for
dangerous territory it doesn't mean it's
permanent but right now i'd say the
warning signs are flashing
[Music]